now next this afternoon two metropolitan
police officers have been found guilty
of gross misconduct after taking photos
of two murdered sisters pc dennis jafar
and pc jamie lewis were sent to fryant
country park in wembley last june after
the bodies of nicole smallman and bieber
henry were found well live disguise
shingi malarikay who's in southwest
london for us uh this afternoon and
during this hearing we heard really some
derogatory language that used by these
two men
that's right nick and both of those
officers have now been dismissed for
gross misconduct and delivering the
verdict was the mets assistant
commissioner helen ball and she first of
all apologized to the families of the
family of bieber henry and nicole
smallman she said that this was a
hurtful dishonest and unprofessional
behavior of the utmost seriousness and
we heard a detailed account of what
happened last year in june when the pair
left the cordon to take pictures of the
two sisters bodies and then send those
pictures on to their colleagues and
wider members of the public we heard a
bit more about some of the language used
by the player including the phrase dead
birds to describe them as they lay dead
and we had those messages read out in
the hearing we heard that lewis sent a
what's that message which said
unfortunately i'm sat next to two dead
birds with stab wounds while jafar is
then
said to have sent a message in a
whatsapp group saying i'm here now i'll
try to take pictures of the dead birds
we also heard a bit about their conduct
after those pictures were taken
including how jafar denied that they
even existed uh while well lewis also
lewis also deleted those messages and
this case has not just this case is uh
has also led to a criminal criminal
hearing earlier earlier on in the month
in which the pair admitted to misconduct
in a public office they will be
sentenced in december and they will
potentially face jail time and alongside
that potential jail time we now know
that they have been dismissed from the
police force as well
all right many thanks indeed for now
shingi